ce n était que vous parti au nom en
vacances il n'y a pas à chercher bien
loin pour se rendre compte qu'il fait
bon vivre à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est en effet la période idéale pour
profiter des nombreuses activités
proposées par la communauté
d'agglomération les communes et la base
de loisirs promenade nature activités
culturelles ou sportives
il y en a pour tous les goûts petite
sélection de thés près batista ton
maillot depuis ses deux petits si tu es
sage
et l'on début de cette émission estivale
avec une étape incontournable pour
profiter au mieux de votre été à saint
quentin en yvelines l'office de tourisme
qui a décroché le premier prix
départemental et le deuxième prix
régional du concours accueille et
sourire 2011 alors j radine que nous
proposes tu pour cet été je propose de
vous promener de vous balader sur le
territoire de saint quentin
sont des balades à faire à pied ou à
vélo en famille ou entre amis avec des
thèmes différents donc ça va 2
la découverte est sourd de la bière au
centre ville et même pourquoi pas des
balades à vélo sur territoire des 50 ans
ce sont des balades avec un itinéraire à
l'intérieur et vous avez également ce
que vous pouvez voir sur circuit vous
avez les informations pratiques ici
aussi que la par exemple si une balade à
faire en vélo et qui dure trois heures
nous proposons également des balades
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite et
les personnes qui auraient une poussette
les terrains sont un peu plus court et
un peu plus accessible
on propose un bal radio guide qui permet
de visiter le territoire d'une façon un
peu plus insolites ce sont d une forme
de petit gps qui vous le sentirez toi le
parc naturel régional de la vallée de
chevreuse propose également une gamme a
trait pour trait complète de balade donc
des balades également à faire à pied ou
à vélo sur territoire du pnr france
miniature propose également un événement
spécialité c'est le tour de france des
plages donc la possibilité de promener
pieds nus sur le différend stable de
plages de france vous propose également
de venir à l'office de tourisme pour
découvrir l'exposition portugal vous
pourrez découvrir les différentes
facettes de ce pays est également
pourquoi pas préparer votre prochain
week-end au portugal c'est jusqu'au 25
août autre lieu incontournable de
l'agglomération la base de loisirs vous
propose en effet des activités nautiques
sportives ou nature avec la ferme
pédagogique et la réserve naturelle mais
vous pourrez aussi faire un petit tour
dans les arbres et profiter de la
piscine à vagues de ces animations
exclusives
c'est une
de prothétique exister l'aqinac de en
france aujourd'hui
5 en europe voilà donc vraiment la
primeur de la voir sur saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est un appareil très utile qu au sein
du très très vite dessus on a cette
sensation de glisse
la vague est quand même relativement
importante puisque on arrive à projeter
trois minutes de la seconde donc on a
une vraie sensation de glisse et
sessions seront environ de 15 minutes
alors on vend de cession de 15 minutes
après il ya pas vraiment 15 minutes de
pratique puisque donc si c'est vraiment
le temps de confirmer va pouvoir surfer
ou maudit surfé sur quinze minutes mais
les débutants ben voilà il va y avoir un
peu de terrain après j'étais sûr de la
piste de la tente on est capable de
faire passer à peu près huit personnes
au quart d'heure donc ça veut dire 32
personnes à l'heure je pense que ça va
être que ça va rester fluide
c'est la sixième édition beach au soleil
donc on a renforcé un petit peu cette
année le beach on veut proposer
encore et toujours de
deux livres des activités nous avons
remis 54 tonnes de sable de
fontainebleau sur l'espace beach et puis
donc au niveau des activités nous allons
avoir les valeurs sûres qui sont très
appréciés du public qui est le sambal
généralement on y ajouter le volley-ball
cette année le rugby on va faire du
badminton de la peteca du speedball nous
avons les deux boulodrome aussi à
disposition et on aura au mois d'août en
or et scalable toutes ces activités là
par contre sont gratuites et à usage de
tous les clients de la banque de la
piscine à vagues voici pour les
sensations mais pour ce qui sera plus
branché calme culture et lecture
n'oubliez pas les terrasses du canal
avec là encore de nombreux services et
activités proposées par la médiathèque
et le musée de la ville et voici
quelques pistes non exhaustive pour
profiter de votre été à saint quentin en
yvelines mais outre la qualité de vie le
développement durable c'est également la
préservation et l'entretien de notre
environnement le développement culturel
ou encore la promotion des transports en
commun comme nous allons le voir dans
nos actus du mois
les longs début de ses actus avec une
info pratique enfin si vous utilisez le
bus sachez en effet que les horaires
d'été débuteront le lundi 9 juillet pour
les lignes ski bus et le lundi 16
juillet pour la ligne 475 et seront
applicables jusqu'au dimanche 2
septembre ils seront disponibles dès la
première semaine de julia sion internet
et en version papier dans les points
habituels mairie médiathèque et au point
information voyageurs de la gare de
monty et le bon plan du mois le voici la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines offre à chaque
habitant une carte annuelle permettant
un accès gratuit à la base de loisirs
pour l'obtenir rendez vous dans votre
mairie munis de la carte grise de votre
véhicule d'une pièce d'identité et d'un
justificatif de domicile
vous souhaitez la faire prolonger
présentez vous à l'accueil de la base de
loisirs muni des mêmes documents et les
amoureux de nature seront heureux
d'apprendre que le 26 août la réserve
naturelle vous proposera d'observer des
oiseaux en canoë sur l'étang de la base
de loisirs une visite guidée par un
animateur nature qui vous permettra
peut-être d'apercevoir une mouette
rieuse eu un balbuzard pêcheur et si ce
n'est pas le cas et bien vous aurez
appris plein de choses comme quoi on
vous met pas en bateau et l'on termine
avec un focus sur les plantes invasives
vous ne savez peut-être pas mais la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines intervient au
quotidien pour entretenir et valoriser
la qualité paysagère du territoire et
cette préservation du patrimoine vert
passe justement par la lutte contre les
plantes invasives des espèces qui se
caractérise par une folie fération
excessive au détriment de la flore et de
la faune locale ou une dégradation des
écosystèmes pas toujours facile de les
éradiquer mais cette action est
nécessaire car elles peuvent aussi être
très allergisante un dossier bien vivre
que vous pouvez retrouver dans le petit
quentin de juillet et août ainsi qu'un
zoom sur les ateliers consacrés au chant
prénatal et un article sur papilles le
pot de l'impôt mais pour l'heure on
retrouve ouais ouais justement pour la
course qu